Support and resistance is one of the
most powerful tools in trading. And once
you actually understand how to use it,
trading becomes a lot simpler. But the
problem is most traders don't really
understand it. They draw random lines
all over the place, not knowing which
one will hold or break. And I know that
because that was me years ago. For a
long time, I was unprofitable. I was
trying everything, new indicators, new
patterns, different systems every few
months, and nothing was consistent. I
felt like I was always one tweak away
from finally becoming profitable
trading. But everything changed when I
stripped my charts down and focused on
one thing, simple support and resistance
[music] with a special tweak. And now,
after mastering it, I trade about 60
minutes in the morning before going to
my full-time job. Shifting to building a
repeatable routine that felt almost too
simple to work is what allowed me to go
from barely making 50 to $100 per trade
to eventually scaling into trades where
I'm making over $5,000
from one [music] single trade. Not
because I found a magic indicator, but
because I mastered this simple
repeatable process. In this video, I'm
going to break down exactly how you can
use support and resistance every single
day to build a profitable trading
foundation [music] that you can scale
with. You don't need to stare at charts
all day. You don't need a massive
trading account. You just need clarity
and a plan. And I want to pass on to you
the five concepts that really make or
break [music] a support and resistance
level. If you can use these concepts
every time to draw your support and
resistance levels, you are going to find
levels that hold a lot more often, which
will in turn make you a lot more
profitable of a trader. So, let's jump
into section one and talk about the
basics of support and resistance. Think
of support as the floor. It is where the
market is more likely to bounce off of
and continue higher. So, with that, you
want to generally be buying off of a
support level. And on the flip side is
resistance. Think of it as the ceiling.
The market is unlikely to go higher from
there, and so it's a good spot for the
market to likely push lower and reverse
down from. The whole idea with these is
support levels are where buyers are more
likely to push the market higher, and
sellers are more likely to push the
market lower off of a resistance level.
And so, what this does is it gives you a
simple rulebook of, "Okay, if the market
is near a support level, I should only
be looking to buy. And if it's near a
resistance level, I should only be
looking to sell." It helps guide you in
the correct direction to place a trade.
And so, there's a few major reasons why
support and resistance levels happen.
You can also think of them like supply
and demand. Big institutions are what
drive a lot of these levels. Now, with a
trader like you and me, it's very easy
for us to get in and out of the market
at a blink of an eye because the amount
of money we are trading is basically
nothing compared to what will move the
market. But these big hedge funds and
banks that are trading billions of
dollars, if they try and buy their whole
position that they want to buy of, let's
say, like $2 billion of a stock or a
market index, it will cause a massive
move in the market to happen, and they
will get a terrible price. And so, what
they want to do is over time, they say,
"Hey, we want to buy at this level of
68.50."
And so, every time the market comes down
to that level, they have a limit order
that will buy and get filled. But the
problem is, because they're trying to
buy so many shares at that level, it
doesn't necessarily fill in one go. And
so, it takes multiple touches for their
order to get filled. And every time it
touches, well, it causes the market to
reverse at that level because of their
big buying pressure that they put on the
market. And so, that's how we as smaller
traders can use these levels to realize
that, "Okay, previously the market has
bounced at these levels, and so big
institutions are most likely buying
there. And so, when it comes to that
level again, you can assume that it's
probably going to continue to bounce off
that level." Now, later in the video,
I'll show you the five key concepts that
I use to confirm whether a support and
resistance level is actually worth
trading off of that can really save you
a lot of money in the long run. Now,
another big reason why support and
resistance levels happen are
psychological levels. Now, what that
means is it's just a big round number,
basically. And so, how you see those is
just looking to the right side of your
chart. And so, a normal psychological
level could be 68.80.
But a bigger one would be 6900.
And then an even bigger one, if I zoom
out just to pull it in, would be 7,000.
And so, these are just big numbers that
are very easy for people to place orders
at because mentally you think, "Oh, wow,
the market here is going to hit 7,000.
That is a big number to either break to
a new all-time crazy number, or I think
that, you know, it's going to hit that
level and people are going to get crazy,
and it's more likely to reverse off of
that." So, those levels can also cause a
lot of movement. Now, support and
resistance levels will always eventually
get broken. And this is because, well,
either at one point the big
institutions, their orders, they get
filled and used up, and the market is
able to move through that level, or just
the supply and the demand of the market
has reached an equilibrium where enough
people that are wanting to sell this
level do not want to do it anymore. And
there's a quite a few reasons why that
can happen. And we'll get into a couple
reasons in a minute of why or how to
know if a level is going to hold or
break. But first, I want to talk to you
about how to tell if a level is strong
or not. Now, the most basic thing is
does it have at least two touches? You
do not want to be just betting that
there is a resistance level here after
the market has only made one clean swing
up into that level because you don't
know how the market has been reacting to
that level. The market has so many ups
and downs in it. The best way to use
support and resistance is to see when,
okay, it has multiple touches in that
area because the third time that it
comes to that area, you can then be
confident that it's going to move lower.
Another one is how clean are the
reversals off of these zones? How fast
does the market move lower? And then
also is what is the range that it's
essentially reversing off of? Is it
always reversing lower in the exact same
price, or is it kind of trending up and
then reversing? That's another big thing
is reversal levels don't necessarily
have to be a straight line. You can have
trending reversal support and
resistance. Right here, this is a great
example of you have a clean touch here
and a clean touch here to make this
trend line. And then the third time is
the market clearly tapped this area and
reversed off of it. And you can have
that on the flip side, too, where you
can have a trending support level that
the market bounces off of. These are
more just trend lines, but they use the
same exact concepts. It's more of just
is it a horizontal support level, or a
trending support level? Now, what makes
a weak level? A weak level is where you
just draw it off of one swing. Often
times, if there is a strong trend in
place, I am not going to be looking for
a new high like this to hold. If the
market here pops up here, and I think,
"Okay, well, it's going to come up here
and sell off because this is a
resistance level," that's really
unlikely because the market trend here
has been so strong. And so, that makes
it more likely to be a weak level. And
as well, it has only one touch. You want
multiple touches to confirm your levels.
And as well, right here, this confirms
that it's a weak level when this price
just breaks right through it. At that
point, I would pretty much just
disregard this as a level going
forwards, and I just wouldn't really pay
attention to it. I would just delete it
from my chart and move on. Now, what you
can see here, though, is what happens on
some levels is it's called essentially a
break and retest. This is where a
resistance level, weak or strong, turns
into a support level. You can see the
market broke above here, came and
retested this high, essentially, and
bounced off of it and pushed higher. And
so, that is what I call a break and
retest. A lot of people use these for
continuation trades, either to the long
side or to the short side, where the
market, there's a level, the market
comes down to it, bounces, and then
breaks, and comes down, pulls back, and
then continues lower. It's a very clean
stair step pattern that the market likes
to follow when it's in a very clean
trend. Some people's whole strategy is
created over those. Another one is a
failed breakout. And so, how that
essentially works is this isn't
necessarily a strong level, but right
here the market came up here, made a
high, and then it attempted to break out
of it again right here. And instead,
what happened, and a lot of beginning
traders will think, "Oh, well, it breaks
out." And so, that means that it's
probably going to break out, pull back,
and continue higher. Well, that's not
necessarily true. Just because it breaks
the previous high does not mean that
it's going to go super bullish and
continue higher. A lot of what happens
is a failed breakout, where it breaks
this zone and reverses back lower. You
can see this exact same thing happen
again over here, where the market barely
broke out of a new high right here,
probably got a lot of people long
thinking that this had a huge bullish
move over these two candlesticks,
chopped here for a little bit, and then
continued higher. A lot of people
probably thought, "Okay, this is a good
breakout trade. I'm going to get long.
There's huge momentum to the upside. I'm
going to stay with the trend." Thinking
that it's going to continue, and it does
a failed breakout instead, and reverses
lower. This is a huge trap that a lot of
beginning traders get sucked into. And
now that you kind of know that that can
happen, you can avoid those spots and
kind of understand why and how to spot
the potential of that happening. And so,
how do you tell if this is going to
break and continue higher or reverse off
of this zone? Well, let me walk you
through a quick checklist to do that.
And to show you that this isn't
hindsight, we'll walk through this
later, but this is a trade I took, where
I made over $5,000 taking a short off of
this area, betting that this was going
to turn into a failed breakout. And so,
the big picture thing though is
generally when in doubt, look at what
the chart has been doing previously. And
previously is that it did a failed
breakout at this level. And so, likely
this level could do a failed breakout as
well. And we have this trending
resistance level that this comes up to,
making it again likely that it's going
to reverse. And another thing is, the
big picture trend here is in a sideways
range, making it again more likely that
we're not going to just start a massive
trend out of nowhere. We're more likely
to stay in a sideways range. Comparing
this to something like this, where we
have this level, which is a weak level
compared to this level over here, this
is a strong level. There's multiple
touches here, a resistance zone you
could make here that we'll talk about in
a minute, and so good reasons for that
to reverse. Versus here, there is a
one-line resistance level, a previous
high here, and the market is in a big
trend here. And so, this right here is
looks more like a pullback, and so you
have momentum into this level, and so
it's more likely to continue that
momentum because it had previously
strong momentum. And big picture, this
could just be a pullback. And so, that's
how I look for reversal trades off of
these levels, and we'll talk more about
how I enter those in a minute, but it's
all about the big picture. When it comes
down to trading, don't get sucked into
the smaller time frames. I use big
picture time frames to confirm 90% of my
trades. If the big picture doesn't
align, there's no trade. I lost a lot of
money and time getting sucked into the
one-minute chart and the micro patterns
of what was going on, when the big
picture just says, "No, this is not a
good spot to take a trade on." And so, I
want to quickly run you through the five
steps that I go through to confirm
whether every support resistance level
is worth trading off of. This is
something I use for every single trade.
And so, the first one is higher time
frames. This right here is a 15-minute
chart. That is a small time frame chart
big picture-wise, if you're thinking
about daily charts, but I take my trades
off of a one-minute chart. And so, it's
15 times larger, basically, than the
chart I trade off of. And so, there's a
huge difference there. You know, if I
look at the current market price here,
where we're trading right now, it's very
easy to see, "Okay, we're in this range.
We had a big kind of strong trend up to
this level, healthy trend here. I am
more likely to think that this is not
going to reverse off this zone again.
It's more likely to break and continue
higher." And then if I go into a
one-minute chart here, it's a lot easier
to think, "Hey, we're just in a strong
uptrend here. It's harder to see the big
picture of what's going on." Compared to
if I just have that 15-minute chart up,
I can see a lot more, multiple days and
weeks of what's happening. And that's
super important for your trading. And
so, no matter what time frame you're
trading, always look and get your levels
off of a bigger picture time frame. And
so, that is step one for identifying
clean levels. Step two is using the
extremes in the market. A great example
is this range that were the market kind
of is currently in right now and
breaking out of is I'm looking mainly at
the extreme levels right here, you know,
where is the big picture reversals off
of, which is where the institutions are
more likely to be trading off of. Versus
if I drew levels off of those extremes,
but then you can see, well, there's a
reversal here. You know, you can make
two touches here. There's two touches
down here from this swing and this
swing. You know, it's very easy to start
to draw levels all over the place. And
what this does is it ends up cluttering
your chart and making you way more
likely to take trades off of levels that
don't matter. You know, what you could
do is you could draw off of this spot
right here and think, "Oh, well, there's
a support level here. You know, maybe we
bounced here a little bit, too, so I can
confirm that off of the kind of these
two touches here." And when it comes
down here again, well, it just blows
right through that because it's a weak
level. Versus strong levels are usually
at the extremes. Think about how that
works. It's the extremes in the market
uh where it's almost so overextended
that buyers on the lows are way more
likely to step in, and sellers on the
highs are way more likely to step in.
Versus if you're trying to trade in the
middle of the range, if you're in a
range, you're way more likely to get
faked out or just trade on a level that
doesn't work out. And as well, we kind
of already went over this, but you want
to see multiple touches. I like to see
see two touches to confirm a level for
taking a trade off of. And so, here I
would try and short this level, and then
here you have these two swings, I would
try and buy off of this level once it
kind of got down to there. That is the
easiest way to confirm that. Now,
another thing is, the fourth step is
strong moves off of these levels. Here
you have a big move off of this,
confirming that this is probably a
strong zone. And so, when it comes up to
here again, it does do kind of a a light
fail breakout, but that's okay. You
know, what you want to see is overall,
and even here is the market takes a
while to sell off of this level, and it
chops around here for a lot, but it
eventually has a strong sell-off when it
hits there. And then the third time,
boom, it just makes a massive sell-off,
too. And so, that can help confirm
whether a level is worth paying
attention to, as well. Now, the fifth
thing I would say is a massive
game-changer for me as a whole, and I
think a big help to identifying these
levels is thinking of them like zones.
Don't think of it like a resistance
level, think of it like a resistance
zone. That the market is more likely to,
once it's bounced off of this area once,
it's more likely to just come up to
somewhere in this zone and reverse off
of. Because it's so unlikely that the
market bounces off of a exact high and
an exact price, the market can come up
here, bounce off the bottom zone, the
middle of the zone, or even like it does
multiple times here, break out the high
of the zone, and reverse. And so, this
is very subjective and can get a little
tricky to do, but generally, to draw
these, what I like to do is, let's say
I'm drawing it off of these two touches,
is I like to use the extreme, the most
extreme of the swings, and then capture
essentially where the the meat of where
the market came up and reversed, and
then pull that across. And then see in
the future where that is. And then so,
here as well, same thing would be here.
These levels are a lot closer, so I
again get the lows at the extreme, and
then kind of get up to the meat a little
bit. You don't want to have your zones
too big. Again, trying to stick closer
to the extremes that where the market
has bounced is better, because again,
that's more likely where the market is
going to reverse. And here you can see
the market does break out of it a little
bit, but eventually it pulls back into
it. And how I continue my my levels is,
well, once this printed and pushed up,
this level's not broken here. The market
didn't break this and continue a trend
lower. It broke this by a good amount,
but eventually pushed back into this
area. And so, what I would do, I would
just move this down here and say, "Yeah,
the zone's a little bit bigger now here,
but I'm going to capture these two
swings here, and then as well, just
capture the extreme low here." And then
I'm going to want to see pull this
across and just see when the market
comes down to it again what that looks
like. And as it came down into here, did
a failed breakout, I would jump in on a
long saying, "Hey, we're at this zone."
Again, it's very subjective. I don't
need it to stay in the zone. I just need
it to be looking for a reversal in this
area. Now, to walk through this start to
finish of how I find a level and then
eventually take a trade off of it, let's
walk through quickly, since we just went
over this, how I would draw this level.
And so here, this is kind of an
interesting point of there's two touches
right here to draw this zone, but also
just keeping in mind that there is this
trend line in place as well. And so to
me, how that works is I think, "Okay,
well, the market's coming up to this
zone here, and I'm going to see if it's
going to reverse off of it." But as it
continues to print, it actually breaks
up higher here, and I think, "Okay,
well, there I know there's this kind of
upwards trend line here. Maybe I need to
draw it like this or even just pulling
it down a little bit." You know, trend
lines are like zones, too. On my
platform, I don't really have a great
way to draw a zone that is kind of, you
know, more trending like this. But
again, thinking of it as like a a zone
of a trend line. The market's going to
come up somewhere up here, and I would
like to see a reversal. And so I would
see it as, "Well, there's a a failed
breakout of this previous high, and it
did come up here and tap this trend line
in zone." So there is great reasons for
it to reverse, as well as looking at the
big picture trend here. There is a good
sideways movement. Now, we do have big
picture, it's kind of a bull flag, which
is a continuation pattern, but that
doesn't mean that this can't sell off
here and continue higher. And big big
picture is the market is very back and
forth right now. And so that doesn't
necessarily mean that this is going to
break out higher because technically you
could say, "Well, we're at kind of a
even larger reversal zone up here from
these two kind of major swings." And so
we might come up here again and sell
off. And so the first thing in my trade
entry checklist here to walk you through
my strategy now off of these zones is
the market has to come up to one of
these extremes where I think it's likely
that the market's going to reverse. That
is the biggest thing that led to my
profitability is I struggled so much and
I went back to the drawing board and
pretty much said, "What am I actually
good at?" I know that I can identify
good support zones or resistance zones
where the market sells off of. I can
pretty consistently say, "Okay, well,
there's a good, you know, support zone
here, there's a good resistance zone
here." Big picture, I just need to
master taking trades off of those zones
now. And so that's what I spent years
trying to focus on and really dummying
down my trading to, you know, go back to
the drawing board of saying, "Hey, what
am I actually good at?" And what can I
make work? And so this comes up to this
level, and you can actually see here
another thing is we're at exactly 7,000.
We're at this big psychological level.
So even though we're not bouncing off
that exactly, big picture that is a
another good reason to add to this level
reversing the market. Again, it's okay
if it breaks it by 10 points here. Not a
big deal. The market does not react to
levels perfectly big picture. Think of
it just as a zone. As we jump into
entering in on a trade here in my
checklist to jump into after we've got
to one of these levels, I've actually
created a PDF guide that you can get for
free that has all the major steps and
checklists that I use to draw these
major support and resistance levels. So
I highly recommend getting that. You can
either get it via this QR code or I'll
put it in the link in the description.
It's just a very easy tool and reminder
you can use to reference in the future.
Now, once it comes to this area, I jump
into a 1-minute chart and I'll pull up a
recording of this exact day. You can see
the market's at that 7,000 level. It
punched up here, and so my checklist is
very simple. The whole idea is how do I
identify now that it's hit this spot I
think it's going to reverse, how do I
identify that the trend is actually
going to reverse off this level? That
whole idea is I'm going from big picture
to smaller picture to smaller picture to
where I actually enter. And so being on
a 1-minute chart, well, that jumps you
down a lot in the smaller picture. And
what I look for is I want to see that
that trend on a 1-minute chart is
essentially broken. And how I do that is
just looking at the swings in the market
of it making higher highs and higher
lows. And how I tell that that's
shifting is that it starts going from
that to making a lower high and a lower
low. That is just a basic market
structure of as you come up, well, a
trend to reverse, it's just going to
start doing this, right? It doesn't
always look as pretty as that, but if
you kind of blur your eyes and try and
drown out some of the noise, you can
start to draw kind of, "Okay, where are
the major swings in this trend and what
are they doing compared to each other?"
And so that's kind of the first step is
making sure that that uptrend is broken.
Now, a big thing I like to also use is I
like to, and it's a little hard to see
on this chart, is I like to see the what
I call is an overextension or an
exhaustive move to one direction. And so
what that looks like is it's essentially
an unhealthy trend. You can see here,
the market here has come up on this
15-minute chart now, it's made a huge
move in two 15-minute candles here. Now,
my candlesticks here are not your
typical red and green. The reason
because of that is psychologically red
and green kind of mess with you
mentally, and so I've just changed my
candlesticks generally to be white is up
and blue is down. It's a little funky to
look at initially, but it's very very
powerful when you're actually trading.
And so here, you can see this is a big
move very very fast. Compared to this
over here, the market's kind of just all
over the place moving up here in a
methodical manner. And so what that does
is it makes it less likely that the
market's going to reverse easily because
the trend up is methodical and healthy,
and so the trend down is probably going
to be methodical and healthy as well.
The market always likes to consistently
repeat itself. And here, well, the trend
is very fast up, so it's likely to be
very fast down. And obviously I don't
know that that's going to happen when
I'm trading, but over time I've realized
that that is extremely important. You
can just look back in the chart and you
can see this happen all the time. Here
is a huge example where the market had a
huge fast move up, chopped around a
little bit, and then the floor just
collapsed and it had a huge reversal
down as well. And so that's one thing I
like to see entering into these trades.
And so going back to 1-minute chart
here, this you can see has this kind of
big move up. It's got this This is
really where that big unhealthy move
happened, and then we've kind of come
down to what I would call is the final
minor support before if it breaks this
zone, it's going to collapse down to
this area where that unhealthy move
started. And then big picture, once that
gets going, if we look at big picture
here again, it can open up the door to
coming down to here easily. It'll easily
make this move back to where that
unhealthy moves, but it could open up
the door to bigger downside. And so
that's the big picture I like to look at
is what is the potential of the trade to
continue going because that's how you
can get really big trades. And so you
can see I have a stop a sell stop order
here if the market breaks this low. And
so And so the final confirmation for me
doing that was we made that lower low,
pulled back, had a big red candlestick
here, and we broke this low here with a
big red candlestick. And so that's kind
of my confirmation that we're starting
that stair-step pattern down of lower
highs and lower lows. And so
essentially, once it broke this low here
that was made, I jumped in with three
futures contracts on the S&P 500 betting
that the market was going to go lower. A
lot of the times I'll jump in right here
when it makes this new low, but because
of just the market here was kind of
choppy, I wanted to see how it broke
this low and pulled back. And so that's
just a minor tweak, you don't need to
think about that. That's just kind of
how trading is over time. Even as simple
as a strategy is, it can be hard to
consistently execute at the same time.
There's always little tweaks that come
into play. And so I highly recommend
starting out simple and knowing that
there's going to be different things to
happen over time. But essentially, so I
jump in here, I put my stop up here, and
then I bet that the market was going to
go lower. And so from there, I'm waiting
for the big picture to play out. It It
takes a little while, goes a little
against me, I'm in the red for a little
bit here, but my thinking was, "Well, I
know that there's this minor resistance
here that we have to break through, and
that could take a minute." And so that's
okay, I'm okay waiting for that. But you
can see here, as soon as it breaks that,
boom, we get a huge flush lower and then
it starts to get moving here. And so
that's what I'm kind of looking for and
you can see here as it moves lower here,
I go break even because I want to take
risk off the table. And then we just
start to trend lower and just like how I
enter in, I like to manage the trade
with the trend. As it's kind of making
these pullbacks and moves lower, I move
my stop loss lower and I try to go break
even and then start to capture some
profits. You can see there's a a
downtrend line that the market's now
respecting. And so once it kind of gets
going here, you can see here it broke
through this minor support level here
pretty easily. Now, I was expecting a
little bit of a bounce here, but once it
gets going, I think, "Okay, well now we
open the door to the next major support
level." And I'm going to assume that the
market's going to bounce off of here.
And so I'm going to target down here
with my limit order just because I think
that's where the market's probably going
to slow down. And so I move to a
trailing stop loss because this gets
going really fast. You know, in a couple
of minutes it goes up a few thousand
dollars. And at this point I'm thinking,
"Okay, well it's it's going to have this
big move down." And think of it like an
unhealthy move. It has an unhealthy move
to the downside here which I'm going to
stay in as long as possible cuz it makes
you a ton of money, but it could have a
snapback really easily. And so that's
why I have this previous high trailing
stop because it was up about 6,000 and
this trade here closes at about 5,000.
So I capture a sick move here and I I
give it a little bit of wiggle room to
keep going, but eventually it closed out
at a spot that makes a lot of sense. And
so if you want to get started trading
this strategy for just $4, check out
this video right here. It will go into
every detail about getting started,
scaling your account, and working
towards where I am now with this
strategy.